ein knopfdruck und schon kann marina
zettel ihr lied in studioqualität
aufnehmen
die sängerin aus österreich testet mike
nie ein kabelloses mikrofon per app
lassen sich die daten direkt
weiterverarbeiten die lautstärke regeln
und einzelne tracks für die instrumente
aufnehmen und kombinieren schnell von
unterwegs vorteil ist es ganz einfach zu
bedienen ist mit einem knopfdruck das
war mir persönlich sehr wichtig weil
bist du dann irgendwie den ganzen sachen
aufbau ist kabel verlegt und die idee
aufnehmen möchtest ist sie vorbei das
bis dahin philipp sonnleitner hat das
kabellose mikrofon entwickelt mai knie
soll marktführer werden der erste
prototyp ist fertiggestellt und konnte
überzeugen
philipp sonnleitner wurde zum peace
festival in wien eingeladen einem
treffen für start-ups aus aller welt
1600 firmen aus 89 ländern hatten sich
beworben
50 duft ihre gadgets einem fachpublikum
vorstellen das ziel investoren finden
es geht nicht immer nur um geld um
menschen sondern auch andere startups
kennenzulernen gestern jemanden aus
südkorea kennengelernt der musikbusiness
ist als man weiß nie was als nächstes
passiert als es sehr spannend
das festival zeigt wie die welt von
morgen aussehen könnte mit robotern die
menschliche gesichtsausdrücke imitieren
wien stammt diese software die
bewegungen in musik umwandelt je nachdem
welcher körperteil bewegt wird erklingt
ein anderes instrument so wird jeder
tänzer zum dj der neueste trend im sport
kommt aus den usa
die firma 11 haus hat fitness kleidung
mit sensoren entwickelt
diese zeichnen auf welche muskeln
beansprucht werden eine app wertet die
daten aus und gibt tipps zum gesünderen
und effektiveren training
wir können einen kind beibringen wie
usain bolt zu laufen und gleichzeitig
verhindern dass es sich verletzt
wir bringen das zu höchstleistungen ohne
die grenzen zu überschreiten
zum ersten mal verändern wir also
menschliche leistung mit hilfe eines
gadgets weil wir den menschen selbst
optimieren
damit solche visionen erfolg haben
müssen investoren überzeugt werden
oliver holle von speedinvest hilft start
up firmen in der frühesten
entwicklungsphase rund 60 millionen euro
möchte er derzeit in neue projekte
investieren die hälfte unserer startup
sie bei uns bewerben denken zu klein
viel zu kleine mich denken in österreich
und deutschland oder in europa denkt in
einer nische und letztlich ist das auch
ein großer unterschied zu den kino
braucht drei charakteren deiner team
einen hacker eine zucker und einen haben
sie müssen gemeinsam man etwas wirklich
interessanten arbeiten und es muss dafür
einen sehr großen macht geben
neun von zehn startups scheitern laut
statistiken beim pioneers festival
glauben dennoch alle an den großen
erfolg philipp sonnleitner bekommt am
ende einer einladung ins silicon valley
und er knüpft eine menge neuer kontakte
mehreren großen verlagshäuser großen
zeitungen content creators gesprochen
bereits leicht einer kooperation
herauszufinden wohin die reise genau
geht im kommenden jahr möchte philipp
sonnleitner wieder dabei sein
vielleicht dann schon als speaker um
anderen zu erklären wie man erfolgreich
die zukunft gestaltet